en nuestro último vídeo nos quedamos
sustituyendo el valor de 2 en nuestra
primitiva que obtuvimos al resolver la
integral medio loca y medio difícil que
tenemos de color azul aquí abajo sin
embargo faltaba evaluar esta integral
esta primitiva en el valor de 1 entonces
hagámoslo de una vez
va a ser 16 pi por 1 pues es 16 p menos
cuatro tercios de pi por uno que es
menos cuatro tercios de pi más no menos
menos éste todavía no estoy
multiplicando por el 69 menos más 4 pi
por 1 y esto le quitábamos y medios por
1 y ahora pues vamos a reducir un poco
todo este desbarajuste que tengo aquí de
pis entonces miren con otro color voy a
tomar índigo 16 y menos ocho pues estos
son 8 pib entonces aquí mesa de noche y
después también aquí tengo 32 32 y 8 son
40 entonces una vez 32 y 8 son 40 pin
muy bien y esto pues no voy a poner aquí
40 p - 8 x 4 son 32 entre 3
treinta y dos tercios menos treinta y
dos tercios del pib muy bien y ahora qué
podemos hacer acá abajo pues aquí abajo
puedo contar el 16 y el 4 16 y 4 vámonos
y son 20 pi y después a este 20 p
yo tengo que sumarle tercios y medios
entonces voy a sacar una vez el mínimo
común múltiplo entre el 3 y el 2 el
mínimo común múltiplo del 3 y el 12 6
entonces voy a hacer una suma de
quebrados y dice 6 entre 16 por veinte
120 pib y después 6 entre tres a dos por
cuatro son ochos al menos ocho y ok
menos ocho y después pues tengo seis
entre dos que son tres por pi son menos
tres pi entonces menos tres y ahora sí
voy a hacer la suma que está acá arriba
120 menos 8 menos 3 es lo mismo que 120
menos 11 que es 109 y sextos entonces
voy a notar aquí 109-109
y en 36 muy bien ojo no estoy
multiplicando por el signo menos que
está fuera del paréntesis al final
cuando haga todas las operaciones voy a
restar el menos 109 y en 36 bueno pero
también como todo estoy pasando a sextos
pues una vez voy a hacer la operación de
acá arriba y esto pues el mismo como un
estrés dice 3 entre 13 por 40 120 menos
32 pi o dicho de otra manera pues es 120
menos 20 100 menos 288 no sé muy bien
entonces 120 menos 32 188 pi entre 3
bien entonces de la parte de arriba
tengo 88 y entre 388 tercios de pi ya
esto le tengo que quitar 109 y entre 6
entonces pues hagámoslo voy a poner otro
color y ahora si el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 3 y 6 de 6
entonces 6 entre 3 a 2 por 88 es de 160
176 muy bien 176 pin y a esto le tengo
que quitar 109
y cuánto es esto espero que no me haya
equivocado hasta aquí creo que hasta
aquí vamos bien y voy a hacer estar
resta 176
menos 109 es 5 y después me queda 165 no
es así bueno entonces lo voy a notar acá
65 pi entre 6 perfecto ya encontré el
volumen de mi sólido de revolución que
estaba buscando el volumen de mi anillo
extraño que yo estaba buscando ya lo
tengo es 65 pi en 36 y es que haciendo
un recordatorio de lo que pasó nosotros
digamos un área muy parecida hasta que
estoy dibujando donde esta parte de la
curva y las otras dos partes serán
completamente rígidas y esta área la
hicimos girar alrededor de la recta x
igual a menos 2 y con todo esto
resolvimos uno de los ejercicios más
difíciles que hay de sólidos de
revolución si ustedes tienen ganas de
que haga más ejemplos de este tema
entonces hágamelo saber pero por lo
pronto en este vídeo acabó esta sección
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo